we are continuing to deal with this
virus outbreak and I'm gonna try to
avoid actually naming it because a
YouTube is flatly d monetizing all
content related to that virus but the
current virus outbreak we're dealing
with is very serious as far as pandemics
go and we're taking it seriously we're
reporting on it there are serious health
agencies doing what they can to try to
stop its spread but one of the people
that in the United States sets the tone
and the agenda for dealing with
something like this is the president and
in this we have seen the president make
it abundantly clear disgustingly clear
that his concern is not avoiding every
unnecessary death or making sure that
testing is being done at the maximum
rate possible it's ensuring that the
virus doesn't derail his reelection in
November at every opportunity his
priorities have been clear downplay the
seriousness of the health situation
portray himself as someone who knows
what he's doing and knows how to handle
it and try to do everything possible to
get this to not be something that
derails his re-election in November
Donald Trump had that absolutely
ridiculous press conference where he
announced that his vice president Mike
Pence who previously prayed when faced
with an HIV epidemic as governor of
Indiana would be running the show Trump
has repeatedly dismissed the entire
situation talking about his tremendous
successes dealing with the virus he
claims to have done the right thing by
closing borders and many other bogus
forms of bragging and the problem is
that this is only making the situation
worse
because if people believe what Donald
Trump says they're more likely not to
take the reasonable precautions that
everybody should be taking every public
statement from the president related to
the virus is an opportunity for him to
talk about how great he is and how
terrible barack obama was in 2014
remember that back in 2014
Trump attacked Barack Obama for not
immediately closing borders over Ebola
now it turns out he bola is actually
much more difficult to transmit then the
current by
we're dealing with Ebola transmission
requires direct contact kovat 19 can be
easily transmitted via a sneeze even to
someone standing several feet away from
you so if you believe Trump and you
believe everything's fine and you
believe as some increasingly do that
this entire thing is completely
overblown in terms of the risk it poses
whatever that means then you're likely
to participate in more risky behavior
than if you are taking the risk
seriously and understand that the
President does not care about dealing
with coronavirus as a public health
situation he cares about dealing with it
as a political situation making sure it
doesn't endanger his re-election and now
Donald Trump if he does change his
approach this week as the number of
deaths increases in the United States
it's not going to be a change of
approach because he's decided he now
really cares about this as a public
health issue it's going to be a change
of strategy because he's panicking about
the stock market and the number of
deaths and the political repercussions
and he is again concerned with getting
himself reelected in November it's the
height of self-centered indifference to
the plight of others something Trump has
a lifetime of experience with remember
disbanding the pandemic response team
Donald Trump did cutting funding to the
CDC attacking people like dr. Nancy
Missoni a who runs immunization and
respiratory disease for the CDC furious
that she had the audacity to speak to
media outlets and accurately describe
the reality on the ground so that health
workers would be prepared and if you
needed any more evidence that Donald
Trump doesn't actually care about
national disasters beyond their
political effect just think back to how
he's dealt with other ones think back to
when Donald Trump wrongly claimed a
hurricane was barreling towards Alabama
causing panic and later tried to justify
his claim by using a Sharpie to draw a
different hurricane path on a piece of
paper then there was the Puerto Rico
fiasco after the terrible hurricanes
going and shooting rolls of toilet paper
like some kind of basketball game
at people needing supplies and then
failing to properly fund and deal with
the hurricane recovery effort so this is
not just about politics if at some point
you thought it was this should be a rude
awakening that this this is life and
death at every level they are simply
telling lies another example is last
week Donald Trump said flights from
China to the US have been shut down
every day you go to FlightAware calm and
you easily find planes coming to the
United States from China like this
flight we're showing our audience from
Shanghai to Los Angeles whose flight map
we have up on the screen right now we
are being lied to it's not about the
dead-end deficit which is bad enough but
it is less consequential in terms of
life and death this is not about you
know lies about the Trump really cut
middle-class taxes or did he mess with
withholdings tables this is something
that is life or death and thousands have
already died and he simply cares about
his re-election that's the reality let
me know what you think I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman quick break back after this
real quick I want to tell you about a
YouTube channel called up flip they're
friends of our show you can check them
out by going to david pakman.com slash
up flip the link is down below
underneath the video every week up flip
publishes a new video where you get to
meet an entrepreneur learn about the
business they built see what it's like
to live a day in their shoes in that
business I love learning about small
business owners the steps they took to
become successful that's why I love the
content on up flip you'll get an
exclusive look at some really
fascinating businesses each entrepreneur
has many valuable insights and
strategies to share about how to build
and maintain a successful company I
would highly recommend their two-part
series on lean manufacturing which
itself is a really interesting concept
that's all about sort of minimizing
waste maximizing efficiency and up flip
breaks it all down you can get to their
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right below
this video make sure you subscribe to
their channel and click that Bell icon
so you'll be notified when they upload
new videos